welcome back to the gamespot stage I'm
your host Chris waters and for our next
board em owes its like a solid block of
PlayStation Vita games of course the
Vita shown up at the sony press
conference a lot of cool games coming to
this one the sony booth over here is
packed with Vita games if you have any
questions on the games you're about to
see just be sure to tweet them at me too
at CT waters use the hashtag gamespot
III or hop into the game spot chat I've
got the room open here it's only one of
many but uh keep them coming and i'll be
sure to ask them first in our crazy
all-star vita lineup is a game called
fly hunter origins joining me to talk
about it now andrew dayton he's on the
couch andrew what's up buddy how's it
going how are you oh it's going good man
I'm really excited because I've got a
vita and its really nice system really
powerful system and I'm really excited
to see more and more developers just
showing off how great it is right you
guys fly hunter origins right on there
yeah it's a you know we are have a few
different platforms you were going to so
its iOS android you know pc steam mac
but the vita is a perfect device you
know it is our game is a platformer
chase game so with the controls their
the screen is beautiful and it is
powerful enough to sort of run the
graphics that we were trying to push so
it's a perfect match for us alright well
we are going to hop into the game right
now actually we've got a demo standing
by but lay the groundwork for us here
because you guys are this your first
game project yes but you've been in
you've been in a different business up
until then you guys been doing a lot of
animation for films well we're still in
that business you still doing that dough
in there and the business way in the
bills of that way well are about the
game the five of us that started steel
wool originally we are feature film
animation sort of veterans between the
five of us there's about 60 years
together yes you guys are like you know
total noobs two kids just really just
left behind here I'm 22 and I started 22
now I made the game and this is what I
look like after making a game game
development is brutal no you know we
like we originally thought like well
let's make our let's make it
and this this sounds like a lot of fun
uh uh uh you know how hard is it turns
out super easy anyone can do it I don't
even show up half the time I just I said
al email so we actually we were pitching
ideas to different publishers and we had
our publisher rip stone and for some
insane reason they decided to like
sharable give you money to make a game
to a bunch of people that have never
made a game before and so what kind of
game did you guys decide to make so fly
hunter is a it's a platformer chase game
it's a high end we always decide I was
gonna be a high-end mobile handheld
console to vita PC Mac and coming from
film the one thing we knew is you know
we sort of know story we know animation
we know design but you know game design
you know creating a game is something
that we're you know we had to learn as
we went yeah and luckily you know the
part of the deal with with our publisher
rip stone is that they have a lot of
experience and they sort of taught us
and spanked our bottom when we were
doing bad things and corporal punishment
a good motivator for you that you know
sometimes that the kind word doesn't
work for me sometimes it is the the
swift kick it's been in it it's been a
really interesting process we r you know
about to release towards the end of the
summer and on top of the five of us
working outside of our day jobs we have
a crew about ten artists you know young
artist one of my partner's Joshua and I
teach at an art college and these were
some of the cream of the crop that we
were able to sort of borrow from you
know they graduate they graduated first
then we go out them but a really
talented crew they've killed themselves
and had to deal with us you know cuz
everything was after five o'clock at
night made a horrible mistake and it's
healthier they're too young to know
better so whatever alright so we've got
this oh this little Cyclops character
stepping past his own dead corpse and
getting instantly abducted by so you're
watching Zack who's our protagonist zack
starts out he is a intergalactic janitor
honest
spaceship well turns out the spaceship
is a crew of fly Hunters fly hunting is
actually illegal and they're a bunch of
poachers so poaching they're poaching
like eyes on this kind of activity on
the game sports they are poaching flaw
human flies and Zach through his uh you
know genius ejects the entire cargo and
crew and it wasn't seem like a thing
that you would want to do no not really
I mean I'm no spaceship Minh I'm no-fly
hunter see the real problem is is that
the fly hunting voyage is sort of funded
by an intergalactic mob and they don't
take kindly to losing the cargo so Zach
being the only crew member left he has
to sort of take the role of fly hunter
hilarity ensues adventure platforming
joy killing bugs flies I so the pursuit
of flies normally you know let's be
honest here flies are gross and also
yucky so what does this guy do once he
gets the Flies this is like fly meet go
for a premium on whatever tiny person
planet come to take you take the fly
down and it's just like you know it
could be an intergalactic afrodisiac
mean you know we don't know what the
purpose is for the Flies but for let
your imagination run or some reason they
are they are really highly valued on the
black market so we don't go into the
back story too much listen when your mob
funded poaching operations it behooves
you to not ask question there you go all
right so fly hunter it's a platformer
yeah you know sort of we saw some
obviously collecting the the scattered
cargo ISM ryori collecting Flibe it's
also important there i mean there's an
overall story i mean one of the things
from our pedigree is that is this a mob
guy right here this this is this is the
mob he's the enforcer he's our sort of
James Bond Ian character if you notice
instead of a sort of stroking the cats
he's stroking the maggot so that's his
his evil pet a giant maggot is far more
evil than a big
they are they are even more disgusting
than flies so the point of this is that
you know we wanted the audience to
really love the character follow the
story but you know as you're playing the
game you're learning about the story
sort of in its not exactly linear
fashion you sort of go into flashbacks
and see what happened and then you'll
see here after each episode there's five
episodes you have to go and hunt your
fly this particular one is the fruit fly
so he is fast and wily aha not a lot of
you know strength so you can take him
down relatively quickly but each fly has
a little bit of a different balance so
this one's a little tough so you
basically treat you track the fly and
then the game sort of becomes this chase
like corridor shooter type thing in the
levels you know there's there's sort of
different motivations for each level but
generally speaking the oval arc is yes
after each episode you're getting to the
fly to bring it down right how I mean so
did you guys have to really you know
obviously you're taking some you're
being very creative when it comes to
character design you got this just dude
with the eyeballs you got the baggage
stroking but like how outlandish to
these flies get I mean you're not just
are you sticking too straightforward
earth variety fruit fly they are earth
riding flies basically this all takes
place our environment is like Florida
Panhandle right so from zacks bridge
with flies so but the thing is it from
Zacks point of view it's this giant
expansive world but it's really all
taking place in the back of a trailer
park Rachel you'll have different
environments like a swamp grasslands you
actually do get to go into an alien
enemy ship you get to go to a beehive so
there's all different worlds that zach
is traversing all probably within in our
space like 30 feet did you guys have
some like mandatory viewings of honey i
shrunk the kids to get to get your mind
sets right for this to get some
inspiration or our reference is wide and
deep there are all kinds of reference
we've had to take some of it I don't
ever want to have to watch again some of
it was you guys just letting some fruit
rot on the counter at work no and then
getting your magnifying glass out oh no
my favorite is the kids sending us
youtube videos of botflies
hey Dayton check this cool thing out and
then you're like you know that's that's
not right it's like googling horrible
horrible horrible varieties of flies
know to see if I you know I could get
shaken by such things do not like it
right all right folks just a quick
reminder we're taking questions on all
of our stage demos to the hashtag
gamespot III on Twitter or in the game
spot chat I relay them to Andrew here
from steel wool about fly hunter origin
not origins is that I heard your origin
sigo thank you I doubt myself sometime
Andrew I'm glad you're here your first
is always the right one clearly I should
go with my gut know what you got but I
is that is that a fly thing guts a turn
up alright so it's mostly on earth
mostly it happening in like sweaty humid
places who are these who are these
characters that get themselves into this
sort of mafia poaching deal because
you've mentioned a couple times so far
during the demo the character that that
kind of appeal and that animation we're
sort of seeing a little cutscene here
now it's you know sort of Zack is the
bumbling fool that has the hero journey
and then eventually becomes this
legendary 500 the backstory for why
they're flying we don't get too much
into that we do have we have the history
but in this in this game we sort of just
let it Zack story right so you do get to
play as the captain of the ship ara and
she is sort of the no-nonsense not very
happy with Zack to begin with since she
was ejected in cryo freeze out of the
ship that does not seem like a place she
wants to be not happy no not happy Zack
angry angry very confused uh so you know
light-hearted sort of sense of humor and
like sort of this kind of goofy almost
like mascot platforming fun times it's
not you know it's a genre that does
maybe see more of a heyday right in
other eras do you guys sort of conscious
of that in developing this yeah when you
know our our first title we knew that
you know we can't reinvent any sort of
game mechanic we all right we can't we
can't do anything and and we're learning
game design as we go yeah now platform
you know platforms it's not that there
any easier there they're actually not
they're very hard to design for a level
design yeah but why choosing a
platformer we knew we had such a huge
pool of inspiration to go to sort of you
know the Metroidvania style of game and
with our character being really
appealing and cute you know we wanted a
really wide audience for this so you
know what I want my seven-year-old son
to be able to play this maybe not run
through it really quickly it be
challenging for him but I want him to
have a real hard time with things I want
him to come crying to me because he
can't be like a no I want him to take
the device and slamming on the floor and
you know get mad and then I have to buy
a new one right I don't know about your
goals man that's weird but those you
know we want to get as many people to
play this and for adults it's you know
fun and charming the story the character
and it is a fun Rob sort of a you know a
throwback and for the kids you know all
the kids that we've you know we've sort
of tested this on it sounds terrible
like we've tested this game on kids
tested on children because their
children right yeah ah they always they
love this character they love sort of a
story it's sort of endearing it's like
you know this bumbling little guy that
eventually gets to the point where you
know you cheves his dream not exactly
straightforward like but he gets there
very cool man yeah so you mentioned a
bunch of platforms in addition to the
Vita let's go over it again fly hunter
origins fly under origins we are on iOS
Android and on the Android platform
we're also because we work with NVIDIA
we have a Tegra 4 specific version and
we are going to be on steam for pc and
mac right up as many places have been
getting when's it all come down the pipe
towards the end of the summer right now
towards the end of the summer towards
the end of the summer all right Andrew
well it's your first game project and
it's shaping up nicely you're close to
the end I wish you luck finishing it
thank regresan on stage I appreciate it
showing off fly hunter origins wait